Okay so, if I go to the documentation and
start writing navigation controller Xcode autocompletes it for me.
It says here that the navigation interface, makes it possible to present your
data efficiently and makes it easier for the user to navigate that content.
So that seems that UINavigation Controller.
Will help me navigate between two different screens on my app.
Cool, okay so if I go back to story board.
I can see that the first screen of my app is right here.
To add another one,
I can open up utilities and add a new View Controller from this list.
Notice that we are adding a View Controller in this case.
All right, I'm going to slide out of the utility area.
And then arrange these View controllers properly.
So here I have the first screen of my app, and
imagine that this new View Controller which for now is empty,
is going to contain a view which will display the second screen of my app.
This screen is going to have all of the buttons,
that will allow us to play sounds.
For now all I want to do is connect this stop button,
to this new View Controller.
Now the way to do this is to press and
hold control on your keyboard, and then drag from the stop button.
On to the new View Controller.
This will present a bunch of options called segueways.
You can think of segueways as transitions between these two View Controllers,
almost like transitions between two different slides in a presentation.
I will select show.
Okay. So the two View Controllers are connected.
At this point, I'm going to try and run the app and see if it even works.
I'm going to press the microphone button.
All right, the recording label and the stop button start to show up correctly.
So far so good.
What happens after I click the stop button?
Hey, hey, here's the second screen of our app, and I also have the back button.
And when I click that, I can go back to the first screen.
Let me try one more time.
This seems to be working.
All right, so there are a couple of things I want to do back in the storyboard.
I can add a title here.
And then try to run the app again.
All right, so you'll notice that the title of the first screen has changed, and
then if I try to go to the second screen the back button there has also changed.
Brilliant.
By the way all of this back and forth navigation, this top bar and
the back button.
All of this, was accomplished by this UI Navigation Controller right here.
So let's think about this, a little bit more deeply.